ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colona madame la ministre la
France en tant que État tiers au conflit
israélo-palestinien doit avoir une
position claire elle doit renouer avec
son rôle historique consistant à
défendre le droit international tout le
droit international rien que le droit
international celui-ci
exige la libération sans conditions de
tous les otages civil la protection de
toutes les personnes civiles la mise en
place en urgence d'un corridor
humanitaire permettant d'acheminer les
produits de première nécessité dont les
médicaments la levée complète du blocus
de la Bande de Gaza l'accès de la presse
pour informer sans entrave et témoigner
de ce qui se passe là-bas en ce sens
lors de l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies réunies vendredi dernier la France
a voté une résolution la largement
adopté demandant une trêve humanitaire
immédiate durable et soutenue menant à
la cessation des
activités des hostilités pardon la
communauté internationale et la France
en
particulier a renoncé depuis plusieurs
années à faire appliquer le droit
international laissant ainsi la région
se gangrainer le cycle de la violence
s'amplifier nous devons agir en
responsabilité madame la ministre alors
que l'armée israélienne attaque en ce
moment même par voie terrestre tuant la
population civile
3195 enfants morts et mettant en danger
les otage détenu par le Hamas quelles
sont les pressions que la France
envisage enfin de afin de mettre un
terme à cet enfer pouvez-vous madame la
ministre affirmez aujourd'hui devant
l'Assemblée nationale que la France
appelle à l'instar d'Antonio gouterz à
un cesser le feu humanitaireè
bien
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Laurence bon secrétaire d'État chargée
de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
d'abord je je vous prie d'excuser la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères kenrine Colona qui participe
à Turin au comité de coopération
transfrontalière du Traité du kirinal
madame la députée candrine Rousseau vous
avez dit que la France doit agir en
responsabilité et vous avez raison c'est
précisément ce que fait notre
diplomatie c'est d'abord en
responsabilité que la France agit au
plan politique vous l'avez rappelé la
France a voté en faveur du texte
jordanien présenté à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies texte qui
appelait à la mise en place d'une trêve
humanitaire menant à l'association des
hostilités c'est la position de la
France depuis les premiers jours de ce
conflit c'est aussi la position commune
des Européens exprimés la semaine
dernière c'est un responsabilité
également que la France agit dans le
domaine humanitaire au 20 millions
d'euros débloqués pour les agences
internationales et les ONG s'ajoute
notre frais humanitaire au bénéfice du
Croissant Rouge égyptien et le soutien
que nous allons apporter à l'hôpital
jordanien de Gaza c'est un impératif et
l'aide doit être acheminée en quantité
suffisante et de manière durable c'est
en responsabilité également que nous
cherchons avec nos partenaires dans la
région et au-delà un chemin qui évite un
embrasement régional et permett de
tracer une perspective de paix le
déplacement du président de la
République les deux tournées de
Catherine Colona dans la région notre
action au Conseil de sécurité en vue d'
l'adoption d'une résolution ont aussi
cet objectif c'est enfit en
responsabilité que nous rappelons des
principes simples la condamnation du
terrorisme du Hamas et des crimes
abjects qui l'a commis le droit d'Israël
à la sécurité et son devoir d'agir dans
le cadre du droit international et enfin
évidemment l'impérieuse nécessité d'un
horizon politique pour que les
Palestiniens et les Israéliens puissent
vivre dans deux états côte à côte et en
paix je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre